there's lots of amazing food in the
philippines but there's one amazing
culinary tradition that's big enough to
feed an army
hi i'm chad and i own buddha fight
manila poodle bootle what what's a
buddha fight
[Applause]
a buddha fight is a feast set up on
banana leaves just a food pile in the
middle with everyone standing shoulder
to shoulder
and the best part is everyone eats with
their bare hands
it originated with the philippine
military soldiers took the practice home
and it went mainstream
so mainstreamed that chefs like jaff now
have full-time jobs bringing buddle
fights to the masses
the bootle fight is a quintessential
example of how filipinos value sharing
especially when it comes to food
a lot of food is needed for willow pie
to be enjoyed the way it's meant to be
we love balintawak market this is where
buddha fight comes together
we'll be needing the essentials pork
chicken seafood
veggies dessert the sides and of course
the fruits and do not forget the star of
the show the banana leaves
i am full already
we start with the messy part the
grilling first the pork
chicken the seafood
and then you slice the fruits steam the
veggies together with the shrimp and the
crab
and then slice all the sides and prepare
the table
after setting up the banana leaves it is
important to look for the center of the
table and start from there
you can place the dessert and fruits
then on both sides start with the rice
pork chicken and seafood
to make it extra delicious
at the sides
literally on the side of the table the
philippines has a lot of choices when it
comes to food
but none compared to the community that
develops when sharing a pile of food
bare-handed with the people you love
[Music]
produce industry does not have the right
to dump nutritious product that can go
to families who are in need
[Music]
borderlands food bank rescues between 30
to 40 million pounds of produce annually
and we've been doing it for 21 years
[Music]
my name is rolanda soto and i am the ceo
president of borderlands food bank
[Music]
we are an organization that rescues
fresh produce we get it to families all
over the state of arizona and 19 other
states within the nation
we saw there was a tremendous amount of
fresh produce coming across at our port
of entry here from mexico and a lot of
it could not be sold
it could be because it had some scarring
it could be because it had some rain
stain and so they were actually dumping
it in the landfill
we saw that the product was extremely
good
for human consumption so we began
educating the produce industry
we've gone to each individual
distributor we've offered them our
services and said do not dump
allow us to rescue it and get it to
families so that they can eat
nutritiously
the driver comes back to the warehouse
he's got a trailer load of product and
he begins to get unloaded
we take up the produce to the sites and
we set it up like a farmer's market all
done by volunteers from the host site
for a ten dollar contribution the
supporter can select 60 pounds of
produce pretty good 17 cents a pound
[Music]
it's important to us to get it to as
many families as possible before it
perishes because i think that people
have the right to eat nutritiously it's
the most basic of needs thank you have a
great day
we have
the responsibility
to stop waste
and we have the responsibility to help
the people in our own backyard
[Music]
people need to understand that all of
north america is indigenous land it is
native land
people tend to forget that there was a
vibrant native culture
living in all parts of north america and
food is really the piece that's going to
help us move forward into a brighter
future
[Music]
my name is sean sherman and i am a chef
i own the company the sous chef
so this is going to be two pieces per
plate for these our mission is
revitalizing native american foods and
re-identifying north american cuisine
we've tried really hard to maintain
authenticity by removing all of the
colonial ingredients like dairy wheat
flour processed sugar beef pork chicken
and we're just using a lot of wild game
a lot of the native agricultural
heirloom varietals a lot of the wild
foods around us and really making those
plates that taste like a region
most of these ingredients are very
familiar to people but the usage of a
lot of the wild plants really talk about
a place in a community
[Music]
we prioritize purchasing from the
indigenous vendors first because we
really want to open up a lot of
opportunity for indigenous people
growing out farms or collecting things
from the wild or raising animals so for
the big dinner we're actually cooking
this bison down with a bunch of fresh
cedar and some bergamot we will purchase
from anybody raising these indigenous
pieces because it is such an important
part of the landscape in the history you
know you want it
[Music]
as we travel around the country we like
to make dinners and foods that really
represent those areas
what's great about being able to do
these dinners especially
in non-indigenous communities is just to
bring awareness this kind of food that
we're eating today like you're going to
feel really good when you leave here
you're not going to feel heavy and
weighted down you're going to feel
energized and just happy because you're
knowing where this food is coming from
we feel like anybody across north
america will benefit from the
understanding of the indigenous food
systems around you and it's all going to
help us move forward
[Music]
it's thanksgiving turkey stuffing mashed
potatoes but the one thing that has
always stood out is a bit of a head
scratcher sweet potato casserole
we're pretty sure sweet potatoes and
marshmallows weren't at the original
thanksgiving so what happened sweet
potatoes have been around forever and
marshmallows this sticky gooey mess
actually comes from a plant and has been
around since ancient egypt a delicacy
only pharaohs could eat okay fast
forward to the 20th century marshmallows
were a big deal expensive and
essentially the chris doll of sweet
treats and not only that but they were
even handmade marshmallows became a
mainstay for high falutin housewives see
back then housewives would have to make
whipped cream or even meringue by hand
but the marshmallows were a modern time
saver the first recipe that paired sweet
potatoes and marshmallows appeared in
1918 in a trade journal cleverly named
sweet potatoes and yams
as marshmallows grew in popularity and
began being mass-produced more and more
recipes began implementing them as an
everyday ingredient
nowadays marshmallows are generally
reserved for campfires and hot chocolate
and this non-traditional traditional
favorite whether you like your sweet
potatoes a marshmallow or plain happy
thanksgiving
[Music]
i can imagine us having thanksgiving
wherever we are in our universe you know
whether it's pluto mars the moon or
wherever i think as we explore as a
civilization we'll take our traditions
with us and break bread in that same way
i spent thanksgiving and space on my
second space shuttle mission in 2009
there were seven astronauts total we
were like around a campfire with no
campfire but floating in the air
my thanksgiving meal was irradiated
smoked turkey
we had thermally stabilized cornbread
dressing
rehydrated green beans
and oh my goodness these other kind of
crazy like kind of candied yams
we always play with our food in space so
i think maybe a green bean or two was
floated over and you you know catch the
green bean it was pretty cool
off the planet you're in this incredible
community of explorers
and that was one thing that i really
felt so connected to is these people
that i'm breaking bread with and being
thankful for
on thanksgiving day i'm sure the
pilgrims or the native americans
probably never would have imagined
turkey in space thanksgiving on mars
would be you know similar to being on
the space station except for your food
wouldn't be floating around because
there's one six g on mars so you know
one-sixth of the gravitational pull on
planet earth you would have your
irradiated smoke turkey on the table
sitting there not floating away
[Music]
you